hey guys i'm cindy palm i hope you enjoy
the highlights from tesla's battery day
if you like what you see while you're
watching don't forget to give it a like
well i mean this is definitely a new
approach we've got the the tesla
drive-in movie theater basically there's
a little bit more
in addition to the battery stuff we got
a little few extras uh as well
so i think uh you'll really like what we
have to say on batteries
the the battery the battery stuff we're
gonna talk about is is truly
revolutionary
uh and essential to uh to tesla's goal
their problems
uh as you make sales larger this was the
challenge that our team
uh set our sights on to overcome and
we did we came up with this tablets
architecture that maybe you've heard
about
the distance that that electron has to
travel and you know it's just much less
this is a big deal people that really
know cells this is a massive
breakthrough
and so when we put it all together and
go to our new
80 millimeter length 4680 we call this
new cell design we get five times the
energy
with six times the power and enable 16
range increase just form factor alone
and you can see nickel is the cheapest
and the highest energy density and
that's why
increasing nickel is a goal of ours and
really everybody's in the
energy in in the uh battery industry but
one of the reasons why
cobalt has even used it all is because
it is a very stable bookshelf
and the challenge with going to pure
nickel is stabilizing that bookshelf
with only nickel and that's what we've
been working on
with our high nickel cathode development
which has zero cobalt in it
leveraging novel coatings and novel
coatings and dopants
we can get a 15 reduction in cathode
dollar per kilowatt hour
yeah it's a big deal
the front and rear of the car is a
single piece um and
then that that then interfaces to
what we call it the structural battery
where the battery for the first time
will have
dual use uh the battery will both have
the use as an energy device
and as structure this this is absolutely
the way things are done
in the early days of of aircraft they
would carry the fuel tanks as cargo
then somebody said hey what if we just
make the wing tanks
what if we just make the fuel tank in
wing shape
so all modern airplanes the fuel tank
your wing is just a a fuel tank in wing
shape
this is absolutely the way to do it
range increase we're unlocking up to 54
increase in range for our vehicles and
energy density for our energy products
uh 56 reduction in dollars per kilowatt
hour at the battery pack level
and a 69 reduction in investment per
gigawatt hour which is the true enabler
when we talk back about how do we
achieve this scale problem here
now to be clear it will take us probably
a year to 18 months to start realizing
these uh
these advantages and probably to fully
realize the advantages probably it's
about three years
or they're about i mean long term we
want to try to
replace about you know uh at least one
percent of the total
vehicle fleet on earth which is about
two billion vehicles
so long term we want to try to make
about 20 million vehicles a year
what does it mean for what does this
what does this mean for our future
products
uh so uh we're we're confident that long
term we can design
and manufacture a a compelling 25 000
electric vehicle um so
you know this this this has always been
our dream from the beginning of the
company
i even like wrote a blog piece about it
um because um
you know our first car was was an
expensive sports car
and then as then it was like slightly
less expensive sedan
and then finally it's sort of a i don't
know mass market premium
but you know like the model 3 and model
y um but it really it was always our
goal to try to make an affordable
electric car
and um i think probably uh
i said about about three years from now
uh we're confident we can make a very
calm
uh very compelling 25 000 electric
vehicle
uh that's also fully autonomous how does
the ice industry look like
for uh in the future
uh well i don't think there will be an
ice industry long term
yeah i mean
well i guess there might be like a few
things that are like it's a like curious
thing like i mean
there's still like some steam engines
made somewhere uh but like they're just
basically
sort of quirky collectors items i mean
that will be the future of the internal
combustion engine car
you know we really try to tell these
companies hey you
really need to do this or you won't
exist in the future
uh but they don't believe it you know so
i mean we've
we've talked until we're blue in the
face what are we supposed to do
um but we really are hopeful that other
companies will also
do what we're doing and that will make
the sustainable future come sooner
basically tesla uh is aiming to be the
the best at manufacturing of any company
on earth
uh this is the thing that's actually
most important in the long run
i think um you know just from a company
standpoint and from
basically um achieving sustainability as
fast as possible
but i think also for long-term
competitiveness um eventually every
every car company will have long-range
electric cars
um i you know eventually every company
will have autonomy
i think but not every company will be uh
great at manufacturing
uh tesla will be absolutely head and
shoulders above anyone else in
manufacturing that is our goal
thanks so much for watching i'm cindy
pom so what did you think about tesla's
big day
did it live up to your expectations i
will be doing a full story about the
significance of battery day
and what this means for the future of
the auto industry so you can watch out
for that in the coming days
a big shout out as always goes out to my
patrons including my patreon producer
nino johnny i will see you all very soon
you